قبل اربع سنوات من الان لم تكن جيل بايدن
زوجه جو بايدن متحمسه لترشح زوجها الى
منصب رئيس الولايات المتحده كاي امراه
تدرس التغيرات التي ستطرا على الحياه
الاسريه واليوم جيل كانت احدى الدوافع
الاساسيه لاعاده ترشح بايدن للرئاسه
على مدى سنوات غيرت جيل بايدنا صوره
النمطيه عن السيده الاولى وبالرغم من ان
هذا المسمى لا علاقه له بصنع القرار
السياسي في المكتب البيضاوي الا ان تاثير
الجل على زوجها كان واضحا بحسب مجله
دون ضغوط على صنع القرارات كانت جل جزءا
من الاجتماعات الرفيعه في البيت الابيض مع
تقديم المشهوره والراي بحسب ما قاله
مستشار بايدن المقربون والذين وصفوا تاثير
الجل باللطيف
وعكس مقوله ان زوجتي السياسيين سلاح سري
لم تكن اسلحه السيده الاولى هذه المره
سريه لتشارك معه حملته الرابعه طوال فتره
زواجهما بل وتوجه فئات اجتماعيه بعيده عن
انتخاب الديمقراطيين الى صف زوجها كما يرى
المحللون
ام وجده وزوجه وسيده اولى استطاعت ان تكون
المستشاره غير الرسميه الاقرب الى الرئيس
الامريكي وتشارك في صنع القرار دون فرضه
عمر العربيه